[音楽]
こんにちははじめ超ですというわけでダイス買いました
ん
はぁ
めっちゃほ救ったんですよバイク昔に撮ってた動画とか
空間がないときバイク乗っていたんですけども逆に最近
最近逆にバイクよくがめっちゃ出てきちゃって買いたいなぁと思って行薬を買いました
こちら
こちらなんていうバイクかと言いますとちー z 125 h s というバイクで
ございます
あの
すまんバイク興味ない人からするとちょっとマニアックな離さんですけどもバイクって
小型と中型と大型に分かれてるんですよもっと小さいので原付っていうのがあるんです
けども
ここで問題ですこのマイク小型が中型か大型かどれだと思いますか
まあ
そうですよね
スランよねパワーなかなかこれぐらい大きいサイズだとだって俺乗ってもせよちょっと
1回乗ってみますね
186センチの僕が乗っても結構大きく見えるぐらいの小サイズなんですけども
某サイズで
こうがあったんだバイクなんですこれやばくないですかサイズか
えっ
なんで中ガードとか o 型にした方が大きくでかっこええやんって思う人いるんです
けどもなんで僕は小型にしたかの理由とは本当にバイクできょうつけなきゃいけない事
とかバイクの事知らないよって人もいると思うんでちょっとまとめてみたのでこちらを
ご覧ください
どうぞ小型バイクのススメ皆さんが行くはどのようなイメージがありますか
一般的には軍といったはず
ないイメージがありますが小型は速くありませんむしろ可愛いバイクが多くてとても
乗りやすいんですね
そして小型バイクが駐輪場に止められますこれは中型大型だとできません
あとこれはとても基本的で大事なことですが
1を引いてはいけません
事故につながる可能性があるのでバイクを運転する際は気をつけましょう
そしてマイクは一般的には重量税やいろんな税金がかかるんですが
小型バイクはそれが少ないらしいので維持費がとても安いです
詳しくはよく分かりません調べてくださいはいっていうメリットなんですよもう1位費
も安いし
俺車乗ってるんで大きな移動は多分車だと思うんですけども細かい買い物とかに細かい
買い物とかちょっとしたお出かけと過去風にみよう
別れたいときとかそういう時にこの子がならだけだったらさっとさっと行けるわけなん
ですよ
でこのかっこよさですよ125 h する方バイク知ってる人しか知らないと思うん
ですけど結構レアなんですよも売ってなくて全国のいろんなお店に問い合わせ予約
ゲットした逸品でございますみたいな見ていきましょうかハイ峠見ていきましょうか
こちらがタイヤですねフロントタイヤ
ん
自分の体は大外を考えるとアメリカが一番自分に合っているのかなって思っちゃいます
ね私みたいかハンドルのこの
くいっくいっていうこの感じこうなってこうなってるんですよこれがもうアメリカの
醍醐味ですよね日本製じゃないんですよ台湾で作られたバイクらしくてもしれない過去
そうした時の帰りのパーツは
ちょっとわからない質なのでちょっと大事に使わなきゃいけないんですね
でまぁほれほれほれとこんな感じを産もうメカメカしくでいいねこの店で買いました俺
エナジーモータースタイルっていうねこれ何がいいかっていうとこれ小型だけど大きく
見せたいんでばっくり荷物載せれるとこついてるんですよ
めちゃくちゃ何かが入るってわけじゃないんですけども何となく物が入る感じですね
で後ろがこの荷物のセルのついてるからなんか余計小型じゃないよっていう大きく見せ
れるという素敵なバイクです
見栄はってます
par
ん
[音楽]
cm
ように今日はあ
前期はめちゃくちゃいいですし新しい財布を買ったということで鍵ついてみましょう4
ドライブスーッとしてみたいからと思っておりますよアウトドライブっていきます
あとに取り入れていきましょう
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
[音楽]
う
me
[音楽]
ん
ええええええ
[音楽]
me
あっハール haro ま